[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
7 voleurs c'est le bonheur de vous
retrouver va se passer plein de choses
dans cette émission et puis on aura
nikos aliagas et pat lecture et qui
seront utiles et loulou
et les loups seule la voix compte je
vais tout cas nous on a le jeu instagram
et je suis giannoulas il sera avec nous
ni cosson lem nikos c'est la première
fois qu'il viendra aller tout de suite
on va passer à autre chose
on va voir en quoi sont les différentes
personnes
on va retrouver je ne sais pas qui va
sortir on a un premier personnage qui va
chanter est ce que ça va être
michael jackson mylène farmer maître
gims ou que françois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole
ça lui va bien patry fans la belle série
c'est parti deuxième partie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
il faudrait il était clair je sais pas
pourquoi
sasol delormeau mylène farmer
[Musique]
je suis dans les bras il a été
clairement l ama et michael jackson
j'étais bras j'étais et enfin bah c'est
pas une surprise qui aurait cru qu'un
vent est tombé à faciliter ses vues
milledge a vu mylène
[Musique]
je
physique
oh
[Musique]